hey there Garden lovers did you know
that certain crops actually thrive in
the cooler temperatures of fall yeah
that's right this means you can extend
your harvest season and keep that Garden
alive a little longer so let's dive into
some amazing fall crops that you can
plant in today's video you're going to
discover five essential fall crops that
can give you a Bountiful Harvest as
those temperatures start to drop whether
you're a seasoned Gardener or just
getting started these crops are perfect
for ensuring your garden remains
productive into the fall months
so grab your gardening gloves and let's
get started now here's the thing many
gardeners often struggle to know what to
plant in the fall maybe you're one of
those folks who just let your garden bed
sit empty as summer Fades away I get it
it can be tough figuring out what will
grow well as the weather changes but
don't worry in this video we're going to
tackle that challenge head on I'll help
you fill those empty spaces with crops
that love the cooler weather all right
let's jump right into it the first crop
I want to talk about is kale kale is a
superstar when it comes to fall
gardening it's cold hearty and can
actually get sweeter after a frost how
cool is that just plant it in well-
drained soil and it'll keep growing
until the snow flies next up is carrots
these crunchy Little Gems are perfect
for fall you can plant them late in the
summer and they'll be ready to harvest
in the fall plus they can stay in the
ground until you're ready to eat them
making them super convenient now let's
talk about broccoli this veggie is a all
favorite because it loves cooler
temperatures start your seeds indoors
then transplant them outside when the
weather cools down broccoli is not only
delicious but also packed with nants
making it a great addition to your fall
Harvest moving on to beets beets are not
only vibrant and colorful but they're
also quite hearty you can plant them in
late summer and they'll grow beautifully
in the fall plus they're versatile you
can eat both the roots and the greens
finally we have spinach ah spinach it's
super easy to grow and thrives in cooler
climates you can plant spinach in late
summer for a fall Harvest and it's
packed with vitamins just make sure you
keep it watered and it will reward you
with a lush crop now here's the exciting
part out of all these amazing crops the
top crop I want to reveal is drum roll
please kale not only does kale thrive in
the fall but it's also a culinary
darling you can toss it in salads blend
it in smoothies or even bake it into
crispy chips Plus plus its nutritional
benefits are off the charts you'll be
doing your body a favor while enjoying
delicious meals straight from your
garden so let's recap the five essential
fall crops we talked about today kale
carrots broccoli beets and spinach each
of these crops offers unique benefits
and can keep your garden productive well
into the fall it's really easy to keep
your garden going with these options and
I hope you feel inspired to give them a
try before you go I'd love to hear from
you what are some of your favorite fall
crops leave a comment down below and
don't forget to subscribe for more
gardening tips and tricks let's keep our
Gardens thriving together thanks for
watching and happy gardening Fallen Leaf
corn carrot broccoli